a finales de marzo miles de haitianos se
tomaron las calles de puerto príncipe
para expresar su descontento por la
inestabilidad política y por el aumento
de la violencia de las bandas no podemos
vivir con el miedo de enviar a nuestros
hijos al colegio no podemos vivir con el
miedo de que serán secuestrados los
secuestros y las peticiones de rescate
han aumentado recientemente en la nación
caribeña tanto que el gobierno declaró
un estado de emergencia de un mes en las
áreas controladas por las pandillas la
situación de seguridad se ha deteriorado
en el contexto de una profunda crisis
política el presidente joven el mois
insiste en que su mandato termina en
febrero de 2022 mientras que sus
oponentes dicen que terminó en febrero
de 2021 el desacuerdo se deriva del
hecho de que moix fue elegido en una
votación que fue invalidada por fraude y
luego fue reelegido un año después
este gobierno ha destruido la acción
parlamentaria la justicia ya no tiene
ningún poder el único poder que existe
está en las manos de yo en el móvil
quien a los ojos de la oposición es un
fraude
protestaremos hasta que todos los
problemas sean resueltos
las protestas antigubernamentales
recientemente han ganado el apoyo de
docenas de oficiales de policía luego de
que muchos fueron asesinados en
operaciones contra las pandillas
mientras tanto otros miembros de la
seguridad han sido encarcelados tras
acusaciones de participar en un golpe de
estado